you
hi everyone its Jared here's another
endgame study this one here published by
a a troitskiy in 1925 it's white to move
if you'd like to go ahead pause the
video see if you can find the best
continuation for white okay the solution
here is to immediately push the pond and
now unfortunately for black no matter in
what direction he goes whether it be
rook h2 will rook to d8 to defend
against the pawn push there's going to
be a fork tactic or ax or we might call
a deflection tactic after rook h2 they
would follow rook F 1 check forcing the
King to the same rank as the rook and
now rook f2 forking the King in the rook
deflecting the rook there away from the
pond push pawn promotion this is a one
ending not the simplest of endings to
win against a computer I did give well I
made a video of the Philidor position on
this ending that video was uploaded in
October of 2011 there is as far as I
know no systematic approach to obtaining
the Philidor position but it at least
gives you some insight as to what you
can be doing when you obtain a certain
position it gives you something to shoot
for
in this ending the other the other way
to go about this one here is after the
pawn push if there a place to d8 we have
a similar idea forcing the king in this
case to the same file as the rook having
to go to the D file and now yet again
this fork tactic and now white is able
to push through so very basic tactic
here being highlighted in this ending of
course and one other detail that I found
quite interesting is that rook c6 and
rook to f1 our other tries that one
might have had but why exactly are these
faulty well if you're inserting a check
first if you do that before pushing
after the King plays here and after you
push now it's true that if the rook goes
here to defend the pawn from pushing we
have this fork tactic
but he can always go here and there's
just not going to be that fork tactic
anymore and the king is going to be able
to hunt down this pawn in conjunction
with the rook and if you tried from this
initial position rook F one check and
only then push well in this case playing
here isn't good because of this fork
tactic but again Black has the choice in
this case you played a d8 in this pawn
is stopped
you could go here to replace here and
yet again black will be very fast to
hunt down that pawn this will end up
being a draw so it's important not to
insert the check first recognize that
you can force the King to the second
rank or the D file depending on where
that rook goes move one so feel free to
leave any comments in the comment
section below as usual and I hope you
got something on this video take care
bye
you